foreign
is already seen throughout the world
blockchain which is advancing numerous
businesses and altering lives is at the
center of the cryptocurrency industry
although distributed Ledger technology
or DLT May disrupt some Industries it
will still nonetheless have a positive
impact on a large number of others
blockchain is already finding its way to
mainstream appeal but when will it be
the Gateway it was safer data future so
to give you a better Clarity over what
future blockchain technology holds for
itself simply learn has brought you a
new video on future of blockchain so
stay tuned to explore more about this an
amazing Topic in this video you will
first learn about what is blockchain
following that you will come across the
advancements of blockchain Technology
till today
then you will see what future holds for
blockchain technology and at the end
what are the expectations with
blockchain technology in the future
but before moving on please do hit the
Subscribe button for more such
interesting videos and hit the Bell icon
to never miss an update from simclear so
let's get started with the video but
before that did you know that recently
blockchain went through a drastic
upgrade that completely revolutionized
the future of blockchain well what was
it stay tuned to the video to know the
answer so first let me take you through
the basics of what is blockchain
blockchain is a decentralized immutable
database that makes it easier to track
assets and record transaction in a
corporate Network
and asset may be physical such as a home
car money or land or intangible like
intellectual property patents copyrights
or branding
on a blockchain network practically
anything of value may be recorded and
traded lowering risk and increasing
efficiency for all parties
information rise Commerce so the better
the faster it comes in and the more
precise it is because it offers
immediate shareable and fully
transparent data that is kept on an
immutable Ledger and accessible only by
users or for permission network
blockchain is the best technology for
delivering such information now that we
have understood what blockchain is let's
have a look at what advancements
blockchain technology has done till date
the world has already been impacted by
blockchain blockchain is at the heart of
the cryptocurrency industry advancing
numerous sectors and altering lives the
most well-known example of blockchain
technology is Bitcoin but more and more
early adopters are joining in for
example there is a blockchain program at
JPMorgan one of the largest banks in the
world friends Barclays accelerator or
13-week program for entrepreneurs that
has been given space and cash to a
number of blockchain based fintech
businesses IBM eastmac codec and Spotify
are among the companies developing
blockchain Based Services IBM has
attempting to develop a tracking tool
for shipping companies and chains while
Eastman codec is experimenting with the
blockchain to build repositories for
stock images and Spotify wants to use
the blockchain to manage copyrights well
now moving on let's have a glimpse over
what the future of blockchain holds
because blockchain is a new technology
opinions on its potential still divided
a recent Trend Insight report from
analyst from Gartner made a few
forecasts like only 10 percent of
businesses will use blockchain to
undergo any significant transformation
by 2022 then at least one cost Cutting
Edge blockchain based company will be
valued 10 billion dollars by 2022 and
blockchain will add more than 360
billion dollars to corporate value by
2026 and more than 3.1 trillion dollars
by 2030. well future applications of
blockchain Technology may open a
worthwhile professional opportunities as
demand increases and blockchain adoption
spreads job opportunities will increase
blockchain has the potential to change
some professions and the Way businesses
approach activities
blockchain disruption won't necessarily
result in the loss of specific
employment in all Industries it might
just be an optimization reflection so
here is a list of the industries where
blockchain will succeed first is cyber
security
blockchain has a distinctively
decentralized nature making it the
perfect instrument for a strong cyber
security infrastructure the primary
field in which blockchain is already
advancing the importance of cyber
security is increasing every day
especially in light of recent cyber
threats and assaults on major
corporations for instance a number of
well-known companies such as apple and
Sony have their data compromised when it
comes to security data Russian might be
a secret Savior for both large and small
businesses although the technology has
been thriving in many areas second is
digital finance and traditional banking
since the financial industry
significantly it relies on the banking
sector protecting transaction data is
crucial blockchain is a ledger that
records all of your transactions to
proceed a payment or open or close an
account Banks needs many days so
peer-to-peer payments are possible using
blockchain this not only speeds up the
procedure but is also economical you
won't be required to pay a third party
or a bank to store your funds A Wider
range of people will be included as a
result of the potential use of
blockchain technology in the finance
industry
third is the medical field
the majority of the hospital continues
to use drawers rooms with archives and
Antiquated storage techniques
alternatively disorganized computer data
with blockchain everything might change
a health worker may need an r or in red
circumstances they used to find the
right information the storage algorithm
will be improved by adding blockchain
patient data are essential to preserve
because of their significance they are
more difficult to access compromise or
corrupt when stored on blockchain blocks
safer healthier people are the result of
secure data on the blockchain blockchain
technology can combat the fraud that
plagues the medical industry it's not
always easy to tell when a drug is bogus
this issue might be resolved thanks to
blockchain technology fourth is cloud
storage a more practical means to store
data cloud storage is used Often by many
people attacks and breaches are common
with cloud storage hackers will attempt
to gain access to your personal
information in an effortrix dot you
blockchain lowers the possibility of
hackers making cloud storage more secure
and difficult for bad hackers to access
now the question that arises is
expectations with blockchain technology
well the potential users for blockchain
technology are numerous the prospects
are vast and the Futures filled with
ones that will come from this Ledger
since it is still a no will concept Port
supporters and directors are interested
in whether it will be accepted or not it
will signify its prominence and
acceptance into our everyday life soon
in the course of time there will be
notable growth in this Arena no matter
if you are a tech Enthusiast or not now
moving on to the question that I asked
in the start of this video
that recently blockchain went through a
drastic upgrade that is ethereum merge
the ethereum merge is a network update
that will change ethereum's consensus
algorithm from proof of work to proof of
state by making this change ethereum
hopes to dramatically reduce its carbon
footprint and create a solid foundation
for future scalability improvements well
do let us know in the comment section
who all of you got the answer correctly
well this was all about the future of
blockchain I hope you enjoyed this video
and found it interesting and informative
if you like this video then please do
share it with your friend and drop a
thumbs up if you have any questions
related to this video then please feel
free to ask away in the comment section
our team will reach out to you as soon
as possible thank you for watching this
video and keep learning
foreign
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here